fun team white again all right if I get
another white I'm gonna have to have to
switch it's just three whites the third
white that I had English ok so if he
five i can certainly rely upon this
square d 5 I'm retaining flexibility
with my dini puns by just playing my
pieces out first and now i'm going to go
with this there is there is one there is
the possibility for the Queen to pivot
on d4 and then swing over to h4 if there
was a capture on d4 not the case here
however so but I do have the possibility
of gaining space with tempo i feel like
i was just i know that i was just
playing this exact game not too long ago
d5 the night plate here and then I
played my night to d2 I think it was
against the computer d5 95-92 I don't
think it works so well so let's see if I
could do something else maybe I just
play h3 with the idea of Bishop e3 h3
seems purposeful
h3 Bishop f5 and then if d 5 night here
is that going to be a 9mm now I think
I'd have something I think I'd have
something for that so I'm clearly just
retaining my cons options I don't want
to get committed I want some more
information I guess if Bishop f5 maybe
then d5 and if the night makes use of a
5 you'll note that night d to not only
defends c4 but it threatens efore with
tempo that was a mouthful right there
what about d5 now believe until this
tension is resolved i'm always going to
be considering this as my candidate move
and very rarely or not really what I
really I wouldn't consider d take see um
what else you I can't move my bishop do
I just push this pawn my night is
unprotected actually there's an issue on
this the queen is setting this pond I'm
just realizing that now so what about
what about this right now let's go with
them let's go with that and well how do
i get my bishop developed let's see what
this night does first if it plays here I
don't know any b3 move i believe is just
met with 94 maybe maybe this maybe in
response to Knight a5 I play Queen d3
and actually another another slight
downside maybe with Queen being on b6 is
that I don't have to worry about this
pond advance getting in you'll note with
the structural change d5 and with all
these ponds are now staggered white
would like to get this pot up here black
would like to get this pawn up to be
five identifying oftentimes your
furthest advance ponds and then trying
to get a pond up right beside it is a
maybe a good thing and now that move is
just one that I did not consider I was
thinking a five and be four but ok it's
jumping into that central square this
tactical idea of night playing here is
not going to still be available I
believe it would be this night can
always move out of the way of this
bishops view on this diagonal width
check sobe 394 Knight takes Knight takes
Knight check Bishop takes rook I'm down
the exchange what about Queen d3 cleaned
III and then I think Queen d3 I don't
have much time let's try Queen d3 seems
okay it's important to note that i do
have a convenient response to Bishop f5
let's just kind of backfires on black
with e4 ok this is believe it's just
backfiring I really wasn't intending
implying something like III to keep the
night away I could do that with pieces
maybe the bishop maybe the rook if i
move the bishop okay there still may be
can some concern over the beep on I want
to be cautious about even winning this
pun like after a series of exchanges
again there's still the potential for
what there's still the potential for the
night to move in an uncover an attack
against d4 so okay how do I capture take
me at the bishop allows Bishop takes
pawn therefore I am down to this being
the best move and okay what's the next
step I believe I could get in b3 Bishop
b2 now I still can't do that as
incredible this Bishop is a pain I can't
move this pond okay do I really have to
play rook be one and then be three it's
incredible b3 keeps failing tactically
yeah
we're about Queen d3 and then be three
cleaned III allow my bishop to take this
pond let's try that actually there's two
reasons to want to move my queen maybe I
want to move my F bomb now now i'm
getting ready to at least get my bishop
on b2 I believe that this is the best
square for the bishop or maybe it was
better to go do rook be one Bishop e3
maybe I should have considered a bit
more what the best square would be for
my dark square Bishop I don't know that
I could really be so certain about
trying to negate this bishops influence
on the board in this corner to corner
diagonal so now this night is out of
play actually i'm not i'm not afraid of
that night the bishop has a clear view
but now i'm gonna run forward this he is
he is a number one minor piece for black
the removal of this Bishop means that
this king is more vulnerable I don't
know if there's going to be a great
attack but okay stay tuned let's see oh
man hang on here I don't know if I want
to allow f4 this is getting a little
more scary than I really would like for
my queen is very very tied down I better
do something though let's do this my
queen is overloaded she's overloaded
having to watch a night in a pun not a
good position to be in okay oh man there
you have it I was overloaded in every
way my phone has a good move you see
what it is there it is I just got my
each but boy do I miss my age pond you
have no idea how much i miss my age pond
the bishop can give a check okay where's
the clock
where is that clock King age too maybe I
can get this pond one day okay that's
check but counter-attacking move this
nights gonna kill me if it gets here
maybe Bishop b2 file by night a4 I could
pick up that pun let's go night here I
don't know if I'd be afraid 94 is the
threat and I get the pawn back on D oh
oh oh man hahaha hang on hang on this is
trouble this is serious trouble okay
well let's take with my rook I'm down
the exchange and upon now haha I have a
deadly bishop this could be dangerous
it's actually not gonna finish is it
look at the clock look at the clock
situation the Queen might be close to
trapped Bishop here is trapping the
Queen she's dead out of nowhere out of
left field right there straight out of
left field she's dead Bishop takes pawn
was also a threat I could have done that
but I'm gonna go after the queen who I
don't even consider that I now that I
should have done this for several
reasons Bishop takes pawn the Queen hits
everything when that Bishop was still
there this is working I got this Bishop
I get that bishop
I'm in check i gotta i gotta take you
got to take when your check like that
there's no time wow good game Alan chess
I think that was the best game so far
you've played several that was either
the best or one of the best man I wanted
to just cook ok let me only go back all
I wanted to do was develop my Queen
Bishop why did I struggle so much what
could I have done better I think the
first suggestion i have is really just
for myself okay this is interesting d 6
queen I don't know how great age 30 is
maybe I should just immediately go for
that and then meet meet the move Knight
a5 with Knight d2 I don't know I guess
again I was still having flashbacks of
the game I played recently and I didn't
really I don't think I got a great
position out of it you guys still still
should have gone with that but anyhow
queen bee six was um it was completely
blind to the fact of night d the idea of
Knight d4 very interesting okay but i
think i think i could work with this
what could I have done better here
what's the solution 94 taking the night
I just get kicked around there's not
really a great square to go to my knight
doesn't have a great square other than
c34 right now so Queen D 30 again be
three I was fearful of just this nighy
for move with tactics huh
yeah Queen d3 okay maybe Queen d3 is
fine I don't know about the bishop move
maybe just immediately playing here is
best although playing here if I'm
playing efore then you could be I guess
relying a bit more on this nights
position but actually I'm never really
in a spot you'll know to play III to
kick the night away because there's
always knight takes Bishop takes and as
was played in the game you snip that
hpop so maybe this is still fine the
bishop move to maybe it's maybe it's
fine maybe d 7 i'm not really I can't be
sure seems seems fine goes back I come
over I think here there's got to be an
improvement there's got to be something
here how do I complete my development
queen how about queen e 2 with Bishop e3
everything solved queen e 2 to defend
this pawn and then Bishop here or up to
be one I don't know these are some other
moves I guess I should have been
considering now I do b3 and then you
open the position up when I'm tactically
vulnerable it's a good point right there
to open the position up when you're in a
position well when you are in the more
aggressive position when I'm still
having to work myself out of tactics
it's almost similar to what you would do
when what is it when you have a lead in
development it said okay you should try
and open up the position to better
utilize the pieces you have out create
more possibilities for those pieces
while in situations such as this one
where I'm still having to weasel myself
out of what this annoying pin you open
up the position the F file is opening up
there's my pieces are just overloaded
this f5 move is very interesting and I
may probably just best it's a really
good move I don't think I'm in a spot to
meet maybe f4 and pawn captures very
annoying although maybe maybe I
shouldn't have been fearing f4 so much
after this f5 move
maybe I should have been fearing this
because of my response g four and then
taking this pawn I still see some issues
with that somehow though with like
counter sacrifices on these squares in
the brook unleashing an attack on my
bishop it's getting very crazy and again
I'm not I'm not in a position to really
cope with the opening up at the position
just yet so I think if I had to do it
over my first suggestion is really for
myself with Queenie to think we need to
with Bishop e3 is going to be better
clean here defend the pond and then not
trying to negate this bishop but maybe
just play to this square root b 1 and b
four might be an idea who knows ok ah
very good game I was busted absolutely
busted not I was saying it when once i
was once i made this move i was saying
it right here not a good position of
being I wasn't quite sure how it was
going to work out and it worked out well
for black winning first upon and then
the exchange this is a strong move very
good pressure very very good how should
you finished it Queen be 4i think the
cleanest way is to just bring this night
back to f6 I this Square and maybe maybe
try and get your queen on this diagonal
to get your Bishop to f5 keep control
over g4 focus more on the Kings side
Queen seems like she's very active but
she's running out of squares very
quickly after she plays to be four and
has night b5 as a response actually the
other thing that I had that I wasn't
even considering his Bishop takes pawn
right now so after Queen before I could
be taking on g6 and if captures it's
going to lead to me so that's that's a
serious threat you'd have to deal with
that right now and maybe Bishop here is
needed you might be having to do
something like Bishop there but that
could get even wild okay this is just a
blitz game but this is going to get wild
too if the bish
plays F Bishop takes bishop if pond
takes then g4 is going to rip open the G
file and if cook takes g4 is there with
a fork but you would fortunately have
Knight takes f for hitting the Queen so
maybe this is ok after all maybe a
Bishop f5 would be needed at this point
but we're both way down on time at this
point ok good game Allen chess